Johanna I understand that you were you  were nervous to meet cube is that right  you were nervous about meeting these  kids and when I get nervous I say things  that are you know I shouldn't yeah how I  thought about I really and I got that  next to him at the table read and you  know I just couldn't I can't I've not  even doing well right now he's even  looking at me did you know that Joe and  I had a kind of a thing for you I have  things for me so you're it to you it's  just of course we're in Seattle and it's  raining what's the big deal love me man  what can I say well Ice Cube yeah I get  the same thing trophy in our Denzel  Washington's love job denzel's love  child  okay I gotta do the best  you